[Music]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to safety ridge
on sunday it's good to have you with us
we are nearly
there the conservative leadership race
has lasted five weeks even if it's felt
at times like five years and tomorrow we
finally find out who will be our next
prime minister liz truss or rishi sunak
and whoever it is they're gonna have to
hit the ground running with spiraling
energy bills a creaking nhs and big
questions about the union all this with
boris johnson looking over their
shoulder he will step down on tuesday
even though some in his party wish he
wouldn't lots to discuss with our guests
this morning and we have got a great
lineup for you to do it with
we'll be talking to the first minister
of scotland nicola sturgeon at this
morning someone who is trust described
as an attention seeker who should be
ignored we'll find out what the smp
leader makes of that
someone who knows a thing or two about
shepherding the uk economy through
choppy waters philip now lord hammond
became chancellor after the brexit
referendum he will also join us live
and the conservative at big beast david
davis will give us a sense of the mood
among conservative mps just a day before
they find out who will be their new
leader
for labour we'll be talking to the
shadow international trade secretary
nick thomas simmons on the show today
and we'll also be trying to find out
just how serious the impact of the
energy price crisis is for small
businesses with abby marshall who owns
the bucking in north yorkshire
plus we'll also be reflecting on boris
johnson's time in the job he always
wanted with someone who was by his side
throughout his one-time chief strategic
advisor number 10 chief of staff lord
lister his first interview since leaving
downing street
[Music]
now unless there's a really big shop
tomorrow liz trust looks set to win the
conservative leadership race and become
the next prime minister one of the most
important relationships for whoever the
new prime minister will be is going to
be with the first minister of scotland
nicola sturgeon someone lives trust is
described as an attention seeker who
should be ignored well we can talk now
to nicolas sturgeon to get her take on
the leadership race but also of course
on the cost of living crisis that is
hitting people across the united kingdom
thank you so much it's great to have you
on the first show back after the summer
recess
now it's almost certain that this trust
is going to be announced tomorrow as the
next prime minister of the uk do you
think she'll be an improvement on boris
johnson
the hard question to start with look
time will tell it's obviously the case
that liz trust and i don't agree on very
much politically but i'm a firm believer
in giving anybody who's coming into the
office of prime minister a chance to
prove themselves and i will certainly do
my best to build a constructive working
relationship with her remember she will
be if it is indeed trust tomorrow she
will be the the fourth prime minister
that i've had to deal with in my time as
first minister and despite my
differences with david cameron theresa
may perhaps less so with boris johnson
but it wasn't for the want of trying
i've managed to have decent working
relationships now certainly try to do
that with liz trust as well and i think
everybody will want to see what she is
going to do she faces as all of us do
right now immense challenges i hope the
very first thing she does in office is
cancel the
looming increase in energy prices the
increase in the energy price cap and
delivers some very substantial help to
individuals and businesses the one thing
i would say is that if she governs as
she has campaigned over the summer she
will be a disaster not just for scotland
but for all of the uk but let's hope
that's not the case because this is a
very serious time for the uk and it
needs very serious and very purposeful
leadership
you say if she governs as she can
campaign she will be a disaster
why do you think that
well because she has campaigned on the
very how can i say this politely niche
priorities of a hundred thousand members
of the conservative party you know
focusing on things like
tax cuts that would benefit the very
richest when is ordinary people across
the country who desperately need help to
feed their children and heat their homes
you know there's been a focus on what
the conservatives would describe as as
walk politics you know rhetoric that
looks as if it is rowing back on the
moral obligation we all have to tackle
the climate emergency which as it
happens is also at the right thing to do
over the long term to lower energy
prices and improve energy security so
the obsessions of a tiny tiny number of
conservative party members
are not the right priorities for the
country so i think it would take very
long to see whether she is going to
govern as a prime minister with a focus
on the real priorities of the country or
not i think that will become very
obvious and evident perhaps within the
first 24 or 48 hours of her premiership
so let's hope she chooses the
responsible course and stops pandering
to
the margins and the conservative party
it does as you say uh feel like we're
gonna find out the direction travel
pretty soon she's uh written uh in the
sunday telegraph today
saying she's gonna have immediate action
on energy bills but also of course
talking an awful lot about tax cuts
are you concerned that if she does push
ahead with tax cuts as we believe uh is
likely to say the least and what impact
that could have on the spending envelope
for
scotland and whatever happens do you
think you're going to have to do an
emergency budget in response to the new
prime minister
well we're undertaking an emergency
budget review right now and we are
committed to setting out the outcome of
that effectively in an emergency budget
within a couple of weeks of whatever
budget or fiscal event the new prime
minister has now we don't know for sure
uh when that will happen or what form
that will take but our working
assumption is there will be something of
that nature by the end of september i
certainly think that is necessary
and to your question yes i am profoundly
concerned about the potential impact of
that on the scottish government's budget
and i know my counterparts in wales and
northern ireland will have the same
concerns i mean right now we are working
within budgets that are effectively
fixed and finite they are not rising in
line with inflation but the inflationary
pressures are bearing down on our budget
as they add on the household budgets of
families across the country any move and
this is a real risk that would cut our
budgets within this financial year would
obviously be of profound concern because
it would have big implications for the
national health service for local
authority budgets for every aspect
of our spending you know one of the
things we've been trying to do within
that finite budget is help those who
most need it we have established a
scottish child payment support that
doesn't exist anywhere else in the uk
currently giving 20 pounds per week per
child to the lowest income families we
have plans to increase that to 25 pounds
a week real tangible help at this time
of crisis and we don't want anything
that reduces our ability to do other
things to help but my other concern
about tax cuts is that they
target those who are already at the the
best off you know many people who are
really struggling right now already
don't pay income tax and wouldn't
benefit from a cut there and wouldn't
benefit in the same way that richer
people would from a cut in national
insurance for example so this is a time
to focus on what is really needed cap
freeze energy prices first and foremost
come to an arrangement then between
government and the energy companies
about how that is paid back over a
longer period of time effectively spread
and share the burden of the soaring gas
prices help businesses because
businesses don't even have the limited
protection of an energy price cap get
more cash into the the pockets of those
who need it most and free up more
spending ability for the devolved
government so we can do more to protect
public services and public sector
workers right now so there's a package
that a new prime minister could bring to
bear and it would deliver real help and
relief to millions across the uk
i guess just to put the counter argument
on uh tax cuts is that liz trust and
those around her would argue that
cutting taxes helps
boost growth which would then uh help
the economy through that sense you
mentioned as well energy bills
and action on energy bills uh liz
truster said she would take immediate
action on that there are reports that
that could include more drilling
licenses in the north sea would you be
happy to see more oil and gas taken from
the north sea to try and increase the
energy supply
but we we've got to make a careful and
just transition away from oil and gas
that's an imperative for the planet
right now but actually it is the the way
that we work towards greater energy
energy security and lower energy bills
we are undertaking right now in the
scottish government our own
energy review looking at the
requirements over the longer term but
you know what is more important i think
than continuing to explore for more oil
and gas is that we fully support
the renewable energy transition so we've
just had an auction round in the north
sea which has given the initial go ahead
to up to 28 gigawatts of offshore wind
energy that's the future and that also
gives us enormous potential in green
hydrogen to help fulfill our own energy
needs but also can be a big export
potential so that's what i said earlier
on we need to support oil and gas as it
transitions and there's lots of workers
in scotland depending on that industry
right now so i'm not complacent about
that but it is the wrong priority if you
take your eye off the renewables at
revolution and the renewables transition
and that's what worries me as well as
irresponsible talk about fracking for
example let's focus on making sure that
we harness our renewables potential
which fulfills all of these important
objectives in the longer term
now i just want to talk a bit about
about independence you have said that
you want to hold another scottish
independence referendum in october
2023 liz trust of course during the
hosting's campaign has said if i'm
elected prime minister i will not allow
another independence referendum so she's
been talking pretty tough on it
if liz trust becomes prime minister do
you think that does impact the chances
of you holding another referendum
well look whether scotland has a
referendum whether scotland
does or does not
vote to be independent it really
shouldn't be up to any uk prime minister
actually it shouldn't be up to a first
minister either this is
about a fundamental principle of
democracy now there is going to be a a
supreme court hearing in october next
month that will look at whether or not
the scottish parliament has
the legal ability to legislate for a
referendum regardless of what a uk prime
minister says i hope the outcome of that
will be positive but of course that is a
a matter for the court you know what
cannot be escaped here you know whatever
list trusts or any prime minister says
is the democratic aspirations of the the
people of scotland you say i want to
have a referendum next year i do but
that said the basis on which i was
elected first minister last year there
is a democratic mandate and my message
to list trust is not
to to say that i think i can persuade
her to support independence she is
opposed to independence she's entitled
to
have that view
but make the case for the continuation
of the union i will make the case for
independence and let the scottish people
decide you know it is not a sign of
strength on the part of list trust to
talk about blocking a referendum or as
some reports today suggest
gerrymandering the rules for a
referendum that is a sign of fundamental
weakness
confidence in her case for the union
let's talk about you mentioned there
about uh as you put it gerrymandering
the rules this is the reports in the
sunday times so that the trust team want
to introduce
a new law that would mean a referendum
could only take place so if a referendum
takes place at least 50
of scotland's entire electorate would
have to vote to leave the union for it
to happen so in other words not a simple
majority as we've seen in the eu
referendum or in the previous uh
referendum and for something you know as
significant as breaking away from the
union and is that something that you
would accept
no because it is a changing of the
basic rules of democracy that we have
all abided by for you know our entire
lifetimes are long before that can you
imagine at the furore
the literal foaming at the mouth that we
would have had from the conservative
party if mdr suggested that for the
brexit referendum you cannot just
because you fear losing a democratic
contest
it's not an excuse or doesn't make it
acceptable to try to rewrite the rules
of democracy that's my point here you
know there has never been a positive
case for the union made
by those who put forward that case in
2014 they tried and got away with it in
2014 to scare people in scotland i
remember back then there was all sorts
of scarce stories of all sorts of things
rather than getting too
involved into
how a referendum could actually uh take
place because another part of the sunday
times uh report is saying that the uk
government wouldn't consider allowing
another referendum unless there was
evidence for more than a year that at
least 60 percent of voters wanted one if
you look at the recent polls i think we
can have a look at the yugov tracker
poll for
support for uh independence and you can
see that it's actually waned recently
and do you think that this perhaps
suggests that you know at a time when
people in scotland are worried about
turning their heating on you know food
banks are saying that people aren't
picking up potatoes because they don't
have the money to boil them
do you think people are worrying perhaps
that independence is a distraction from
the cost of living issues
well
it's not a distraction and part of my
job is to persuade people of that
because part of the reason within this
mesh right now is because we're not
independent and therefore we don't have
the levers to try to navigate our way
out of that scotland was independent we
could already
have passed an emergency budget we'd
have powers to reform the energy market
to deal with some of the underlying
causes of this i wouldn't as first
minister of scotland be sitting here
right now as we were discussing earlier
on profoundly concerned in case a prime
minister in london that scotland hasn't
voted for is about to take decisions
that cut our budget even more we
wouldn't have a position where we have
to accept that people are relying on
food banks some of the action we have
taken the scottish child payment that i
mentioned earlier on we could build on
that because we'd have access to more
levers and resources actually
independence is much
more necessary when we're dealing with
crisis because it gives you more levers
to navigate your way through and on to a
better future but the point i wanted to
complete it wasn't about getting to the
substance you asked me about all of
these different stories about attempts
on the part of uk governments to
gerrymander the rules
only
politicians fearing the democratic
outcome it would ever contemplate that
let's have the debate on substance where
i and my colleagues will make the case
for independence for scotland becoming
like other independent countries across
the world able to navigate our own
future and let people like liz trust
make a case for the union but then
democratically let the people of
scotland decide that's how democracy
works it's how democracy should always
work um you at the beginning of the
interview you were talking about your
relationship with other uh previous
prime ministers i just want to touch
upon your personal relationship with liz
trust because obviously personal
relationships do matter
in politics and i think i can just play
you what liz trust said
at a hustings in august about you when
she was asked let's have a listen
i feel like i'm a child of the union
that i really believe we are a family
and we're better together and i think
the best thing to do with nicola
sturgeon is ignore her she's an
attention seeker
that's what she is
she's an attention seeker that's what
she is
are you really going to be able to work
with liz truss
i will do my best and it is up to his
trust to decide whether she wants to to
work with me let's put the personal
insults to one side again coming back to
the argument i made about if you're
confident in your case you don't need to
try to block democracy or gerrymandered
democracy similarly i'd say
just to come in because it just applies
i do think
you don't make
just a comment because i do feel it is
slight a two-way thing with you guys i
have to say you recently said that the
main thing liz trust wanted to talk to
you about uh when she met you
uh i think um
quite recently uh was how she could get
into vogue i just been interviewed by
vega said that was the main thing she
wanted to talk to me about
i remember it because we were there at
the world's biggest climate change
conference in glasgow and that was the
main topic of conversation she was
interested in pursuing just talk me
through what happened there
i was asked a question if i'd had a
conversation with liz trust it's the
only
uh
lengthy conversation or meaningful
conversation i can recall having with
let's trust so i answered the question
about what we talked about and look i'm
perfectly willing to put not to put our
political differences aside because in a
democracy you have political debates but
i will as i did with david cameron
theresa may
to some extent boris johnson i think
most people would recognize that was
more difficult to build a working
relationship
i'm not perfect i'm not saying that
i'm blameless when those relationships
go through difficulties but i will try
to build that relationship but the point
i was making is that her comment about
ignoring me is in a similar vein to
trying to block democracy you don't make
a problem that you fear you can't solve
uh properly go away by simply ignoring
it you engage in attention then debate
and
i'm a politician i mean part of your job
as a politician is to get attention for
yourself your policies your values um i
mean i don't mean this pejoratively but
i've never looked at let's trust and
think thought that she was
some kind of shrinking violet and that's
not a criticism in politics that's part
of the job that you you have to do but
the ignoring point is perhaps more
fundamental because look people and some
people in scotland vote for me and my
party some people don't some people like
me some people loathe me that's
democracy but i am the democratically
elected first minister of my country and
that means quite a lot of people have
voted for me and when they hear liz
trust saying i should be ignored you
know what they hear is that scotland's
voting choices should be ignored or that
scotland should be ignored and i tell
you something i think people in scotland
you know are really getting increasingly
fed up with tory prime ministers that
remember we don't vote for and wouldn't
vote for if we'd had the chance with
list trust trying to ignore and talk
down scotland and that is one of the
many reasons why i think increasing
numbers of people in scotland will
support scotland being an independent
country so that that important
relationship with the rest of the uk is
on the basis of equality
okay now we are out of time but there's
just one thing i would like to ask you
it's something that i've spoken to you
about uh before i know it's something
that you feel uh strongly about um this
week my colleagues liz bakes and agnes
chamber have been looking into
allegations of sexual misconduct and the
culture
in westminster and really this crosses
across all different parties what
they've been looking into
one former snp staff member told them
the attitude in westminster is if it's
not rape it's okay
of course there have been allegations
about members of your own party the
commons watchdog found patrick grody
sexually harassed a junior member of
staff he of course has since quit the
snp
are you happy with the way that your
party has dealt with these allegations
of sexual misconduct
um no i think we can be better and i'm
not going to shy away from that i think
every party every organisation dealing
uh belatedly i think because too often
in the past these are things that have
been swept under the carpet i think
we've all got lessons to learn i said in
the context of the the patrick grady
case that we had lessons to learn and
that is the case so we are looking at
our procedures as a party
as parliamentary groups all of the time
we've gone through a very painful
process as the scottish government and
because of issues you and i have spoken
about previously and some of the the
security and the pressure i've had over
the past few years on these issues um in
particular the highest profile one of
these is because i've not been prepared
simply to sweep these things under the
carpet so no i don't think we are as
good as we need to do and that's
something i take seriously and i'm
intending to ensure that we do get
better so that women or men who feel
that they have been
the victim of sexual harassment or
sexual abuse feel confident in coming
forward and feel confident in the
processes that they then use
okay thank you very much nicola sturgeon
their first minister
of scotland
well in a little over 27 hours we're
going to be no we're going to know who
is the new leader of the conservative
party and the prime minister of the
united kingdom it's been a long and
grueling contest we've had hours of
husting social media spats policy rows
stitching the conservative party back
together again is not going to be easy
well our next guest knows better than
most how rishi sunik and liz trust are
going to be feeling today uh he lost in
2005 to uh david cameron hate to remind
you of that
david davis thank you very much for
being uh with us
well it looks pretty certain doesn't it
that liz trust will be the next leader
of your party how do you think she's
going to get on it looks like it looks
likely i mean we're not we're not sure
until we see the ballots of course and
it's a really difficult uh electorate to
uh to censor but the but how's well look
she faces probably the second most
difficult
uh brief uh in their post-war prime
ministers i mean the only person with a
worse brief coming in was margaret
thatcher i think the country was
bankrupt and all sorts of other problems
but
so she's got this huge set of problems
obviously the cost of living crisis
backing off from ukraine uh and also
within that the energy crisis really
really difficult i actually don't think
any of the candidates not one of them
going through it really knows quite how
big this is going to be it's going to be
on a par with the furlough scheme in
terms it's going to be tens of billions
of costs it's going to be rewriting
markets it's going to be intervening and
that's what you think should happen
that's what should happen that's where
it has to happen i mean yeah you
we worry about and we talk a lot in
politics about the vulnerable of course
they are the most important to deal with
but also small businesses and businesses
generally employment the whole economy
is going to take a shock if you can sort
it out so so that's got to be done and
that's huge and it will it'll involve to
some extent putting your ideologies on
one side you know you know we're all
free marketeers we're all low tax
enthusiasts i mean more than most i
guess um but we're gonna have to think
well actually for this next 12 months
i'm going to do something different so
you've got that coming and then a whole
pack of other things behind it on the
tax cuts i'm interested because as you
say you know you are someone who
ideology ideologically like the idea of
tax cuts and believe in low taxes
liz trust of course has talked a lot
about low taxes as the way forward but
do you think that actually that is not
the right thing to do uh in the short to
medium term because well i mean the
first thing to understand we talk about
tax cuts what she's talking about is
cancelling tax increases that's the
first thing and this is quite an
important difference um i'm not too
worried about the the national insurance
cancellation actually that will now end
up given the way that rishi amended it
as being a net tax cut because he's
taking 70 percent out of people out of
it the corporation tax i think they're
gonna have to think quite hard about
actually um i'm i again i'd like a low
uh headline tax but these days vast
amounts of corporate money goes to
buying back shares and propping up their
own share price and so on i've got to
think about how that works so so there's
quite a lot to be done there but in
principle uh it's the right direction
but she's going to find balance in the
books really difficult if i'm right
about the costs of the energy crisis
tens upon tens of billions of pounds in
a short not in the long term but in the
short term uh and you add to that the
necessary increase in defense costs
because ukraine you add to that
necessary increase in in nhs costs it's
going to be quite difficult to make the
books balance and the worst outcome is
as it were to give low taxes a bad name
by going down a route which leads to an
increase in uh in interest costs
massive increases in people's mortgages
and or a decline in the pound the
pound's been going down
systematically over the over the last
year or so if it drops off a cliff then
we're going to have more inflation so
that it's it's this is a really really
difficult balancing job it's not for
nothing that margaret hatch actually put
taxes up earlier in her in her years now
i don't think that's the right thing to
do either but the but it's difficult one
point i'm making is a knife edge
calculation she has to make i mean
actually say it is difficult it's a very
difficult outlook it's gonna be a bumpy
road whoever ends up winning uh tomorrow
are you can you say with 100 certainty
that whoever wins tomorrow assuming it's
liz trust will lead the conservative
party into the next election
it's that's only two years away so it's
a 90 something percent probability but
more more more more
pressing than that in a way is what you
sort of intimated when you introduced me
and and that is that there is a real
risk the party will sort of feel divided
yeah you know um and that means if
that's the case we won't win the next
election
and so it's going to be really important
that she
pulls people in so would you what do you
think that the cabinet needs to involve
different people from different factions
to the party
would you like to see rishi sue nack
offered a job i would i mean look the
greatest mistake that boris johnson made
i mean
there were a few but right back at the
beginning and it sort of slightly
shocked me
was the fact that he basically created a
cabinet of loyalists you know it wasn't
a meritocratic cabinet it wasn't the
best people you know uh jeremy hunt was
offered to demotion so obviously didn't
take it uh others like liam fox or
indeed penny morton wasn't in cabinet
you know which absolutely justify the
place uh and there were other i could
give you a list of half a dozen who
should have been there and who might
have
talked to him and talked him out of some
of the silly things he did ranging from
some of the mistakes on kobe through to
the mistakes and handling the house and
looking at the people who were talked
about as being in the next liz trust
cabinet are you worried she was going to
make that absolutely i think i think
that look it's it's always tempting you
know if you're going to win this sort of
thing you've had people been around you
since the beginning you want to you want
to be loyal to them and so on but
actually your your loyalty is to a
bigger entity your loyalties to the
country and the party and
that's hard that's hard to do on the
first day so well i think you should
brace yourself and do it what kind of
job do you think rishi sunk for example
should be offered what you could
offering foreign secretary uh he'd do
that very well she won't want to put him
in in back in as chancellor because i
have very different views on that and
that's public um i mean
something very senior so in top half
dozen anyway do you think that she might
be tempted to call an early election
uh no actually um everybody talks about
it the oppositional court always called
for it as well
um but no i mean we've got an 80
majority you know um there was a
suggestion when boris was
going out as it were that he might call
an election and the suggestion came
right back from the palace and we may
not grant one you know the the
conditions for an election are you need
to have one to deliver a majority in
other commons there is there not that
need at the moment and finally on boris
johnson there are rumors
that he could be persuaded
to come back
um well rumors probably coming from
boris johnson's camp i i i dismiss most
of this stuff about a a resurgence of
boris boris has got some really tough
times in the next few months what was
the privileges committee and so on um
and people i mean you know if he if he
had not gone because of the resignation
whatever it was 50 ministers the very
next week the party would have
passed about to no confidence in him
that's why that all happened we forget
that that he lost the confidence in the
party and i don't think you'll get that
back in a hurry okay thank you very much
uh indeed daily davis uh there well we
were just talking of course about uh
boris johnson and the removal vans have
been in and out of downing street uh
this week as he prepares to stand down
from the job he always wanted as prime
minister well his premiership has been
many things but you couldn't say it
wasn't memorable
this morning i i went to
buckingham palace
and i am forming a new government
tonight we are leaving the european
union for many people this is an
astonishing moment of hope
i was at a hospital the other night
where i think there were there were
actually a few coronavirus patients and
i shook hands with everybody uh you'll
be pleased to know i must give the
british people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home now i'm just
hearing at this moment that the prime
minister has been taken into an
intensive care unit
we've been asking for action
as you know on coal cars cash and trees
ukraine
will win
and britain
will be by
your side all guidance was followed
completely during number 10. i apologize
i apologize unreservedly for the offense
that it has caused up and down the
country we're just hearing that uh
sajid javid has resigned i think rishi
sunak has just resigned as we've seen
at westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves i want to thank
everybody here and
hasta la vista
baby thank you
[Applause]
hasta la vista baby well one person who
knows boris johnson better than most is
lord lister eddie lister who's been by
his side
all the way back to when he was mayor of
london and i think we can see a couple
of photos of him here he is by boris
johnson's side at the announcements of
the winner of the conservative party
leadership in 2019 he then became mr
johnson's chief strategic advisor and
then downing street chief of staff so if
you want to know about boris johnson
he's a man you want to talk to
and here he is thank you very much for
being with us today
you know as i'm you know i'm looking
forward to interviewing you because i
feel like you perhaps know boris johnson
better than anyone i've actually
interviewed before on this programme so
you know when on tuesday he you travels
to barramura to meet with the queen how
do you think he's going to be feeling oh
very sad um
i mean this is a job he always wanted
and um it is it was the pinnacle of his
um political career and so he's going to
be very sad that day and uh he's also
going to look back and he's going to
um i am sure
just
just feel that you know what if it's the
old what if business what if some things
were done differently would it have
ended up like this it's hard to ever
know but it's not going to be a nice
journey for him you say kind of what if
and of course as you say this is a man
who always wanted to be you know prime
minister i think he was talked about
wanting to be world king when he was a
child so remember that um
do you feel that he'll be frustrated
that he didn't even manage three years
on the job
oh yes yes of course i mean and and i
mean he has been um taken out of that
role before his time um and but but i
mean i think it's
naive to believe that the party was or
mps were not going to go for him at
various times um and so
to some extent he's he's been
on ice for a little bit a bit of a while
now um while he's dealt with some of
these various issues do you think that
his premiership will be seen as a
success
i think in hindsight yes um because i
think he has achieved a lot what what
specifically well i think the first
thing um has to be of course that he
defeated jeremy corbyn um and jeremy
corbyn could have brought in and he was
a very strong candidate and could have
brought in the labour government a very
left-wing labour government that's a
campaigning success isn't it
what as prime minister well immediately
you must move on i think to brexit
brexit was completed and achieved
against enormous opposition in
parliament enormous opposition within
the courts and it was a very painful
process he completed that he also um was
the prime minister over covet and
undoubtedly and perhaps we could talk
about this i don't know um he it was his
drive to get vaccines which you have to
credit him with that above every anybody
else
but that was a tough time and then of
course ukraine
without his commitment to ukraine i
don't think um america or europe would
have been as robust as they are you know
uncovered
because obviously you were right there
in the room where as many of those
decisions were happening he had a sort
of ringside seat
another person who did was dominic
cummings he has a very different take to
you he describes boss johnson as his
shopping trolley veering all over the
place in january he said it was his duty
to get rid of boris johnson's prime
minister saying it was sort of like
fixing the drains
has he got a point no
i'm i'm sorry i i don't think he has and
um i'm very sorry that um
the dominic felt he could no longer work
for boris um he he was um he was a very
talented man
but i think he was just plain wrong on
this
what you've got to remember with covet
is that right at the beginning nobody
knew anything the advice was
contradictory
everybody was saying different things
there was a moment in time where it was
um the the
the advisors were saying heard immunity
was the answer don't do anything then
the next one was you've got to get
vaccines that's the essential one then
it was don't wear masks they're not they
don't work then it was wear masks the
advice coming in to him
and like plenty of other examples was
was always contradictory so he had to
make judgments and you must remember it
nearly it nearly killed him so he was
very personal about it he knew what it
was like for people to have um to have
got to that point where they were
intensive care did it shake him that
that experience because you see the sort
of bombastic side of boris johnson you
know kind of shrugging it off trying to
get back to work the puppy gate trying
to stop him uh from you know going down
to refusing to isolate from number two
oh that wasn't right no
yes it did shake him it did shake him i
always remember one one conversation and
it was one of those many conversations
down i i can't remember now where it was
done on the zoom from within the
building it was done shouting through
the door um but it was it was he was
went into a coughing fit he said god
this is awful
that was i think the first time i
realized that he was ill really ill
because he's not somebody who reacts to
illness at all and that's the moment um
so it did shake him yes i think there
was a lot of anger of course as well
about the feeling that
rules were stretched and in some cases
broken
in downing street when everyone else had
to follow the rules i mean you were
there at the time were you at any of
those parties that were investigated no
i wasn't um but then um come friday
night i wouldn't want to be around
downing street i wanted to go home um
and and to be absolutely fair um he
wasn't either i mean a lot he received a
fine from the police yes he did for for
a particular incident yes he did and
that was that was the one where um he as
a surprise um
somebody brought him in a birthday cake
um just before the start of a meeting
and rishi sanak also got a fine for that
as well i always thought that was deeply
unfair actually because he didn't set
out to have a surprise birthday cake
that was actually just before i can't
even remember now today what meeting
that was it was one i wasn't at so i i i
don't know um oh no what i was going to
say was that most of the the incidents
of parties were not parties as you or i
know them they were people um
some of the younger staff having having
a drink um at the end of a friday when
they when they've been there all week
remember nobody was at home they were
all in the building there are these
questions about integrity which
in the end led to boris johnson's
downfall you know whether it was being
fined by the police over over party gate
his handling of these allegations of
sexual misconduct with chris pincher
frankly his relationship with the truth
as well he's been investigated over
whether he misled parliament
many people look at him and think this
is not a man of integrity i don't agree
um he is
i've never known somebody um quite as
tough on this as him he is
um a very very straightforward
individual um he would never knowingly
break the law that is not him he
genuinely um in those instances you
talked about the
um
and he's apologized for them um he did
not believe he was breaking the law he
wouldn't have done it if he'd believe
that there have also been questions
about your own uh conduct as well uh
while they're in in government you're
also director of edward lister
consultants and advisors to the property
group de lansi non-executive director to
stan hope holdings
is that not a conflict of interest not
really no um they were not things no no
firstly they were all declared i mean
let me be quite clear about that
and secondly um i was i was still doing
a little bit of work there for myself
but it was nothing to do with any
government work it was all to do with
very specific
work for it in fact it was largely shut
down while i was in parliament so no i
don't believe there was anything and and
certainly it was all stuff that i
declared but if it's declared does that
not mean if you just declare it then you
can effectively just do it yeah i
suppose you could do it that way but i
didn't i virtually did nothing while i
was so why do anything at all then if it
was virtually not well because i when
when i went into downing street i went
in for a very short period of time i was
originally going in for three months
and and then that changed to get brexit
done
in the general election and then just as
i was going to leave kovitz struck so i
stayed longer than i ever planned to
stay
and that was that was the reason um in
hindsight i should have completely got
rid of those things but how much money
were you making oh it wasn't much it was
very little what what does that mean no
no i'm not going to go okay in fact i'm
not pretty sure now but it was it was it
was very small let's look forward uh the
new prime minister uh is going to be
we're going to find out who it's going
to be tomorrow who would you like it to
be
i think now um
and and having watched the debate as
it's unfolded i i think liz trusts
because i i am one of those who believe
that you can't do what you've always
done
and get the same result and so i think
we do need to change
and i think the proposal she's putting
forward are going to bring about a lot
of change i think they're going to be
very hard it's going to be very
difficult
i wouldn't end envy anybody entering
into downing street um
on tuesday it's going to be tough but i
think she's probably the best person for
the job yeah as you say it is going to
be tough uh the such a situation that
they're going to find themselves in in
number 10 and number 11 is is going to
be almost sort of unprecedented in
memory
what policy platform would you like her
to take forward
i think the important thing is she's got
to deal with the big issues she's got to
continue boris johnson's legacy over
ukraine and got to stay robust over
ukraine because i still believe that's
the single most dangerous issue that's
out there i know it's it's not top of
everybody's list but it is
the most dangerous one um the second one
is of of course cost of living and she's
putting forward a number of proposals on
that she's talked about tax cuts she's
talked about um some targeted help she's
not spelled that out yet and i'm sure
she will be doing that and she's also um
talked about a rethink about energy and
i think that's right because we it's not
just a short-term problem there's also a
long-term problem here that needs to be
dealt with
there are some reports
that conservative mps and members are
experiencing a bit of sellers remorse
over boris johnson
well so they should uh sorry
i mean i i i just think they um
i think they did the wrong thing i i
think they overreacted i think they
they got too much into their twitter
accounts and um stopped um thinking
straight and i don't think it was a good
move i think he was the best prime
minister we've had i think he would
continue to be a good prime minister i
think he would be very successful if in
a further general election however
that's yesterday that's gone um
so how's it going do you think we might
be tempted oh well maybe in the future
i'd never say never on anything with
boris johnson um
anything is possible in the future but
for now we have a new leader and as as
he said yesterday um the party now needs
to rally behind and the mps need to
rally behind the new leader so never say
never do you think he'll it may be that
he gives liz trusts a chance to see what
happens but
if as someone once said the ball came
loose at the back of the scrum
look
he's he is an amazing person he is full
of energy he works extremely hard he is
going to be watching all this and if
something happens in the future as you
said with the ball comes loose in the
scrum then
then all things anything can happen i'm
not going to predict all i'm saying is
um i would never say i would never write
him off okay thank you very much
fascinating to uh talk lordless to there
thank you
well let's talk uh now about the cost of
living crisis that really has been at
the sort of center of our interviews
this morning uh one thing that really
struck me over the summer is the
disconnect between some of the political
debate in westminster and what people
are experiencing in their own lives
across the united kingdom and whether
that's what's happening in your local
school or hospital or trying to work out
on earth your wages are going to cover
your energy and food bills you know it
seems to me more important than ever to
hear some of those voices and to put
those real-life experiences to the
people who have believers to do
something about it our political guests
well there's only one place to start
this week energy bills we've been
looking at the impact on small business
who of course aren't protected by the
price cap now a typical pub was paying
about 15 and a half thousand pounds on
energy that's expected to rise to just
under 50
000 pounds according to the british beer
and pub association up more than 200 per
cent
now the industry employs some 940 000
people and there are around 47 000 pubs
in the united kingdom
so we can talk now to the owner of a pub
to find out what is going on this
morning we're going to take you to
thornton la dale a very picturesque
village in north yorkshire at the center
of that village is the buck inn we can
talk to its owner
abby marshall now thank you so much for
being on the program
this morning abby uh just talk with us
through first how much of your energy
bill's gone up
uh so just to put into context uh we
bought the pub in september 21 so
11 12 months ago
uh we are not connected to maine's gas
here so we run off an lpg tank
uh the when we filled the tank when we
moved in september 21 uh to when we
filled the tank four weeks ago that had
gone up 285 percent
uh we're due to get our new electricity
bill um which we are predicting uh is
due to coming on monday which will be
300
so if you add that all together i'm
predicting sophie my utility should go
from about 22 000 to about 58 000.
wow so that really is you know a big
rise you must be hit by food price
inflation as well yeah and i think the
problem is as well so whilst um
obviously everybody's talking about
utilities at the moment and it is
extremely important for the past six
months you know hospitality and all
small businesses we've been seeing
direct cost of doing business
escalating uh
beyond what we've ever seen before and
the problem is
you know when you're running a small
business or any business and you're
trying to control your costs and every
single direct cost of your business is
escalating at a point that you have no
control over it
uh it's very worrying cost of food cost
of beer
utilities uh vat for example vat was
five percent that's gone to twenty so
we've just paid our first vat bill at 20
which was
excruciatingly painful business rates as
well you know they're 50 at the moment
um but again they're due to go up to 100
so what you're looking at is uh you know
you're forecasting and you're looking at
your p l and
and every single line on your p l is is
just growing and it's not stopping you
know it's just completely escalating and
then there comes a point where you um
you can't streamline your business you
can't look at your business and say how
do we deal with these costs because
every single one of those costs really
is out of your control
it's really uh you know we spoke about
your the increase your energy bills know
when you told my producer that fish and
chips has had to go up from 12 1995 to
1795.
300
absolutely just a silly example sophie
you know 1295 september 21 1795 now what
we started doing as well is we've
started moving away from menus permanent
menus just because uh the price
fluctuation on on product and inventory
is so up and down at the moment that
what
if we were to physically print a menu i
can guarantee within three to four weeks
a lot of those prices will be obsolete
um so we've gone to specials boards uh
where we can change the you know change
the pricing week by week or every couple
of weeks the chefs
are continuously looking at price point
um
and i think the scary thing is how
quickly it changes uh that's definitely
something that's that sort of really hit
home for me is the speed in which it
changes is the fact that you try and put
it together a set of figures and within
a couple of weeks those those aren't
correct uh you're behind
it's really uh you know it is a bit of
an eye opener to be honest you know
talking to you this morning and just
getting the kind of real world example
about what rising inflation actually
means it's one of those words you kind
of chuck around and in political
interviews and you don't really think
about the real world examples in terms
of you know fish and chips or a pint of
your pub and yeah of course all the
people that rely on those businesses as
well
liz trusts we believe or maybe russia
soon are going to be setting out their
plan uh to deal with the cost of living
and energy uh in the coming week
what do you need what if you know if the
next prime minister was watching this
now what do you need them to do i think
i think there's a few things sophie well
from my perspective and obviously i
can't speak for all smes and small
businesses but i think obviously vat
jumping from five to twenty percent has
been a huge a huge issue for us i'd like
to see a cutting vat
i'd like to say see a holiday on
business rates which you know i mean
we've been talking about business rates
for a decade it's it's um
it's a system that doesn't work it's not
representative of the market as it is
now so i think that whole system he's
looking at and i think there needs to be
a cap on utilities you know ultimately
we're an employer um just an example
we're in a very small village but if we
were to go uh you'd be looking at 15 to
17 people without jobs so when you start
looking at that's just one small pub in
in a small village uh the scale of of
the problem uh times that by you know 30
000 pubs and that's just hospitality
never mind your bakeries and your cafes
and your other small businesses
so v80 business rates holiday and a cap
and utilities would be a start but then
i think we've got to think about how do
we future-proof our businesses moving
forward um we unfortunately are very we
use a lot of energy we have fridges we
have ovens we have cooling systems we
have sellers
uh there's got to be some sort of
long-term um idea of how we move forward
as a sector and what we get you know are
we gonna are they gonna enable us to
install green energy are we gonna be
able to install solar something just to
future-proof yourself from this
happening again
thank you so much it's been really
interesting to talk to you this morning
abby uh and you know good luck in the
months ahead let's hope there's
something for you um sophie
well we're going to be talking to people
like abby and just getting some of those
real world examples uh every sunday uh
going on well time now to get the view
from labour because the party of course
keen to focus on the cost of living
crisis and has put forward its own plans
on energy prices we can talk now to
labour's nick thomas simmons who is the
shadow international trade secretary
thank you very much for being with us
this morning
uh it looks like liz trust is going to
be the next prime minister would she be
an improvement on the last one
uh well first of all very good to join
you this morning uh sophie uh whether
she will be an improvement uh on boris
johnson who frankly that trashed the
office of prime minister only time in
the end will tell uh what i've seen over
the summer frankly are two conservative
leadership candidates living in some
sort of parallel reality i think of the
constituents who are emailing me who are
speaking to me whenever i'm out and
about who are so fearful about the
pressures on family budgets this winter
and yet the conservative party has spent
well over two months talking to itself
and left in place a zombie government
that frankly has been doing nothing over
the summer whilst people are so
incredibly worried
it certainly does feel like people are
concerned about the cost of living
crisis going forward um she has said of
course
that she wants to have immediate action
on energy bills to try and you know help
families and also businesses and then
tax cuts some people listening to that
might be thinking that sounds pretty
good
well we'll have to just see what
is actually brought forward next week to
be able to judge that i mean the debate
over the summer has not particularly
shown a focus on what people are facing
or indeed an understanding of the scale
of the crisis
but what we are saying very clearly is
freeze energy bills freeze that price
cap so people are not paying a penny
more and take that worry away from
people and also i listened with interest
sophie to your last interview we also
need to be putting in place
support for businesses and what labor is
saying is we would be putting in place a
contingency fund of a billion pounds for
energy intensive businesses in addition
to that we would be raising the
threshold at which business rates are
paid
before then actually reforming business
rates and we'd be raising that money
from an increase in the digital services
tax we've got to be helping households
we've got to be helping businesses as
well
um i'm also interested to uh know uh
your take on whether or not there might
be an early election there has been a
bit of speculation is labor on an
election footing
we are absolutely on an election footing
and i want to see this government swept
away as soon as possible these are
continuity candidates and part of the
conservative debate over the summer has
been about all the problems that have
been caused by 12 years of conservative
rule to sweep this government away we
need to have that general election and
we in labor want to see that general
election happen as soon as we possibly
can so we can get on with the job of
rebuilding our country's economy and
standing beside people in this acute
cost of living crisis that looks like
it's only going to get worse in the
months ahead
um we spoke to lord lister also earlier
on the program of course someone who's
been very close to boris johnson for a
long time and he said
that he wouldn't rule out a return
to frontline politics for boris johnson
if the ball came loose at the back of
the scrum he wouldn't rule anything out
do you think that boris johnson
could come back
it really does show the depths to which
the conservative party has sunk and the
fact that they are so
tired after 12 years in office that
they've just ousted a
leader after his flagrant disregard for
kovid rules after he showed time and
again it was one rule for him and
another rule for the rest of the
population it really does show now the
conservative party has completely lost
its way if they they are saying credibly
that they want to get rid of one leader
then try to have a leadership contest
with others then try and bring the other
leader back the only way we're ever
going to get a fresh start is to sweep
the conservatives away completely
okay thank you uh very much uh indeed
nick thomas simmons there for the labour
party
uh well it is hard to believe just two
and a half years after the biggest
contraction in the uk economy for 300
years we're talking about what could be
a bigger economic crisis than covid
energy prices soaring with war in
ukraine inflation at levels not seen for
40 years concerns about poverty and
vulnerable people struggling to heat or
eat it's pretty grim and it will of
course be the political background for
years to come so what should the next
prime minister do well philip hammond
became chancellor in the economic
uncertainty after the brexit referendum
he joins us now thank you very much for
being with us pleasure um i'm very
interested to hear your take on what the
economic picture actually is and what
the next months and potentially years
could look like how bad could it be
well it looks to me that it's very
challenging in the short term
but i think that the longer term
prognosis is a bit better um for the uk
if i were advising the incoming prime
minister
my advice would be to be very honest
with the british people about the
challenges we're facing in the short
term and how we're going to deal with
them
of course the government is going to
have to provide support uh to deal with
massive energy bills in the short term
um but i think the incoming prime
minister's got to be clear about what
the government can do and what it can't
do it can help with the short-term
pressures the the bit of this uh in
energy inflation which is temporary
cyclical related to the war in ukraine
but what we're talking about here is
people not being able to afford to heat
their homes
and the government will can and should
intervene to help with that short-term
pressure
but to the extent that some element of
the increase in energy costs is going to
be structural long-term
as we
seek to become more energy independent
in the future as we seek to decarbonize
in the future
government's got to be honest with
people that represents a change in our
priorities for consumption
and i think this has always been a a bit
of an issue that we've had about being
open and honest with people about what
the decarbonization agenda over the
medium and long term what does that mean
in layman terms
it means you mean the green agenda the
green agenda it means that energy
is going to be more expensive
than it was before the current crisis
not the levels it is now because those
levels are driven uh to a very
significant extent by short-term
temporary factors um but but we are
going to have to face the fact
that to
decarbonize our economy to
tackle global warming um we are going to
have in the long term higher energy
prices than we were used to having a
year a couple of years ago and i think
the government just needs to be honest
and open um with people we also need to
be clear that the short-term measures
that that i'm sure will be announced in
the next few days uh to help people over
this winter have got to be paid for
somehow they can't all just be done
through borrowing we're dealing with an
inflation crisis
borrowing adds more stimulus to the
economy that is exactly the opposite of
what we should be trying to do to dampen
down inflation by finding a way to pay
for it do you mean spending cuts it
means re-prioritizing and that's what
people around the world are doing
they're saying look we've got this
program over
that does reprioritizing mean spending
cuts it means postponing or delaying
things that the government might have
wanted to do in the winter of 22-23
we need to push that money into helping
people with energy bills just as people
would do with their own budgets if a
problem comes up you you immediately
reprioritize that's what you do the
government has to do the same it can't
just go out and borrow hundreds of
billions of pounds more because that
will only
that will only um stimulate more
inflation you're concerned that the
truth is what liz trusts effectively
will be doing well i'm i'm i would be
concerned if that was what the new
government decides to do i don't think
it will i think it will certainly want
to do some borrowing um but i hope that
it will do some reprioritization as well
reflecting the fact that inflation is
the challenge
reflecting the fact that inflation is
the challenge we've also been talking an
awful lot about tax cuts um which you
soon could also clearly list trust at
seeing tax cuts as a priority something
that the ifs has said that could add
to the
inflation would tax cuts out of
inflation yes i mean tax cuts now um uh
everything else being equal would uh
deliver an inflationary stimulus that is
not the right thing to do i think david
davis tax cuts aren't the right thing to
do right now i think david davis said
earlier and i'd agree with him that um
we are a party that advocates low taxes
we need the new government to have a
very clear set of conservative
philosophical principles including the
desire to contain the state keep taxes
as low as possible but those have to be
the long-term guiding principles for our
policy agenda in the short term we have
to be pragmatic and cutting taxes
at a time when we have a huge deficit
160 billion pounds probably
this year of government borrowing when
inflation is the major problem we have
to tackle is simply not the answer and
and of course the other thing is
throughout this decade the 2020s we
always knew we were going to have
exceptional pressure on public services
because of the aging profile of our
population if the government can manage
to hold taxes stable that will be an
immense achievement in my view um liz
trust has acknowledged this morning that
her tax cuts would benefit the wealthier
more than those on lower incomes or of
course those and benefits as well um
does that add to your view that right
now is not the time for tax cuts well it
depends how you structure them but i
think there are many reasons why tax
cuts in the immediate future will not be
the right way to tackle this crisis i
think
the government needs to provide targeted
support to those most in need around the
immediate crisis over energy bills and
we don't know what the future is going
to be but there is a good chance that
energy inflation will abate
during the course of 2023 and we will
find that we've got over this immediate
crisis
um you were also talking about borrowing
and uh the concerns that you have about
borrowing are you worried that the
conservative reputation for fiscal
responsibility you had the austerity
years of course uh with george osborne
uh you were someone who i think was
described as eeyore by some of the
tabloids in your time are you concerned
that the conservative reputation for
fiscal responsibility is at stake right
now
yes and i'm concerned that the
conservative reputation for competent
government is at stake and i think the
new government
needs to
decide from day one to be honest with
the public
to reach out across the tory party and
beyond to show that it will be a
government that governs for the whole
country
that it's a government that's
underpinned by a clear set of principles
and values and those would include sound
money balanced budgets uh paying our way
in the world good tory principles but
that it is also pragmatic and it will
deal with the specific problems that
we're facing like the cost of living
crisis right now so a strong set of
underpinning values that inform our
long-term agenda but an absolute
commitment to pragmatism and competent
government competent management on a
day-to-day basis who did you vote for
uh i haven't endorsed either candidate
uh publicly and i'm i'm not going to do
so now okay um is there
okay
reading between the lines it feels like
you may be more on the rishi soon next
time than the liz trust night am i
overstepping look i i look at the
bookies odds i look at the polling and
i'm pretty sure we're going to have a
trust government i've worked very
closely with liz trust she was
chief secretary to the treasury while i
was chancellor she was a formidable
chief secretary she works very hard she
is very diligent
and i think she can make a very good
prime minister but
she must do it by being inclusive she'll
send a clear signal as early as tuesday
when she starts to form her cabinet and
it must be a cabinet that reflects the
talent across the conservative party and
sends a message to the country
that this will be a government that
focuses on delivery on competence on
honesty and on applying those values in
a pragmatic way nicola sturgeon on this
program said she was no shrinking violet
would you agree with that description
oh she's a tough cookie um and anyone
who's anyone has had to deal with liz
trust as chief secretary to the treasury
negotiating their spending settlement
will
know that very well i know her as a
colleague as somebody who got things
done
and that's
a rarer commodity than you might think
in government but you asked her to do
something it would always be done
and uh that that's a pretty good
credential for being prime minister uh
we are out of time but just uh quickly
there's some speculation that boris
johnson could mount a comeback eddie
lister lord lister told me earlier on
the show that if the ball came loose
from the back of the scrum he wouldn't
rule out boris johnson picking it up
what do you make of that
i think this is fantasy i think um boris
has not been a good prime minister i
think he's damaged the office of prime
minister i think he's damaged uh the
tory party um and i think boris will no
doubt have a very successful career
in other fields in the future and i
think he should move on uh and uh put
aside any idea of hanging like a sort of
malevolent shadow over the next
government he needs to let let the new
prime minister get on with his or her
job and make it clear that he's moved on
as well i do think that he hasn't done
that yet then i think he hasn't done it
yet okay thank you very much indeed uh
phillip halland
uh well a big program uh of course uh
today because it's gonna be a very big
week next week tomorrow we're gonna be
finding out
who will be uh the leader of the
conservative party uh tuesday is when of
course we will be finding out the prime
minister resigning and then on wednesday
will be another important day the first
meeting of the new uh cabinet the new
prime minister facing the commons for
the first time at prime minister's
questions and we can add to that list
the return of our midweek programme for
take as well uh so do uh come and join
us at 9pm on wednesdays it's our chance
to take the political temperature in the
middle of the week with some big
interviews a bit of analysis from the
journalists data on the state of play in
uk politics and a panel of viewers to
give us their take uh on all of the big
political news now if you want to be
involved in that conversation then do
please send us an email at the take with
safety ridge at sky dot uk the email
should be on your screens right now just
a couple of lines about yourself
and your politics and it's going to be a
pretty extraordinary week next week and
next wednesday as well so definitely
want to tune into there
well that is it for this week sophie
ridge on sunday it is good to be back in
a moment after the break we'll be
running through today's interviews
finding out what we learned with our
deputy political editor sam copes thanks
for joining us this sunday morning
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]